ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final president
of the United States!
-(cheering and applause)
-Right. Wow!
Thanks for agreeing to pay
for my border wall.
Yeah, the whole thing?
And free burritos for life?
Thanks. Thanks,
the president of Mexico.
-Mr. President, Mr. President.
-Mr. President. -What?!
Mr. President, uh,
Robert Mueller has assembled
a grand jury in the Russia
probe. Do you have any comment?
Unfair. I'm supposed to be tried
by a jury of my peers.
Where are they going to find
12 presidents
who are allegedly being
blackmailed by Putin?
Why does your immigration plan
place so much importance
on the ability to speak English?
If you want to live here, you
need to talk English very good.
As a president
who English great,
me know job good.
Is important for job do.
Me stand with good American
like local milk people.
So true. So true.
How do you respond to reports
that the White House
-is in chaos?
-No, there's no chaos.
And that's why tonight's theme
is chaos.
You just said there's no chaos.
Right. That's why
tonight's theme is order.
I have a new chief of staff,
General John Kelly,
a very tough guy.
And I trust the general.
He gets me the best
car insurance rates online.
Which, as we all know,
saves some time!
Kelly has done such incredible
work with deportation.
This guy tears families apart.
And I can't wait to see
what he'll do to mine.
You want... you want him
to tear your family apart?
What? No.
Maybe. I don't know.
Some of them?
Our theme is chaos.
I thought it was order.
You're out of order!
I'm the president.
Chaos believe it?!
Let's roll!